are you kidding me that looks great
sorry I'll clean you up but like
oh my God
hello everyone my name is Tucker and
welcome to my tiny messy kitchen look at
this thing I'm also I'm a big guy so I
mean maybe it would be less tiny for you
but like come on now look ready I'm
opening
it's so tiny so a little back story
about me and this household I am the
messy roommate and my roommate is very
very clean so he has challenged me to
utilize the space in a way that makes us
both happy so he has challenged me to
transform the kitchen by using
techniques hacks items I found online to
make the kitchen more usable and clean
and you know what make this tiny kitchen
work for us
you can't see the sink right hey camera
up
no that is off limits it is time we
transform this kitchen into something
that is beautiful and utile is that the
word
okay let's get started
so when poking around online something I
consistently saw was to use shelves okay
we're not working with much space here
but we got a lot of vertical space here
look at this right okay so as much as
this affirmation wall to-do list photo
wall has been nice to look at it's time
to get rid of it throw up some shelves
and let's get rid of this affirmation
wall sorry Mom you're out
foreign
that'll hold a small child I did need a
little help from Producer Mike thank you
it was a little more labor intensive
than expected hopefully that's like the
hardest thing we'll be doing today let's
make sure that these actually this does
work I don't know I don't trust myself
but come on now this is heavy too could
only do so many reps of these okay so
that works that looks great okay let's
try some other things so I found online
these magnetic spice holders look at
this
are you kidding me I can't get enough it
also came with these little labels so
like you got everything here you got
all-purpose allspice Caraway not quite
sure what that one is I don't have all
of those but I do have my spices here
from this messy cabinet so this is going
to clear up a lot of space I'm thinking
like line them here because then this
thing opens with ease let's add some
more what should we do okay ground
cinnamon for sure next because I'm
starting with the ones that I use often
and by often I mean once a year because
I like never cook I'm obsessed with this
okay let's talk knives this is the
current knife Stitch it's a free-for-all
we just throw like the cutting knives
and stuff in here we got a whisk in here
we got a knife in here so that needs to
change the steps to fix that would be
like a knife block but no we can't have
that now can we because like where's the
counter space so a fun solution going
back to our magnetic theme is a little
magnetic knife bar slap this bad boy on
the fridge and now we can start hanging
up some of our loose knives because
we're adults and that's what an adult
would do that's not hold on okay that
part sticks there you go look at that if
I have eyes on the knives I can be
careful but when they're in here I don't
have eyes on them who knows what they're
going to do that's fantastic I'm loving
this
okay it's time to go under the sink our
current situation under the sink is kind
of just you know throw it under there
close it and forget about it so that
probably has to change we have a couple
things that we can do that we're working
with we have a little overhang basket
we have a little command oh my God if I
didn't break it we have a little command
strip basket that also can be placed and
then we also have a little extra storage
area and get this ready for this ready
to be blown away oh wait oh I'm holding
it the wrong way a little slide out
storage I think that my method here is
going to be like what do we use the most
under this sink what do we not use a lot
because the dishwasher is right here I
slap this over here like what if like
what if okay so now in here look again
we're working with that vertical space
now come on literally stop everyone stop
stop rolling are you kidding me I have
an idea I have an idea stick with me
here we go come
the two things I use most dishwasher
getting another trash bag one thousand
percent not what that's for
but it works for me and my household
okay so that's what we're gonna do okay
I'm gonna put the little caddy up give
me like four hours
this is incredible look at the amount of
space I have in there now
so much space I could throw a party for
ten so in an effort to clean up our
silverware drawer that had just a bunch
of measuring cups kind of laying about
we thought hey why not work with a
hooker too okay
a hook or two
that sorry about that so here we have a
wonderful six hooked thing my vision is
to slap this up here stick it down and
just kind of have these things dangle
and then look at this ready ready
it'll well it'll be stuck in there so
obviously that won't happen but I mean
that just clears up some space and it's
cute if you're wearing socks you might
want to preemptively take them off
because they're about to be blown off we
got it at Ikea and ready for this ready
for this
oh it's like an accordion
you may be thinking what in the world
could that be it's it's to hold your pot
lids so our current method is kind of
what some would call a scavenger hunt
it's a free-for-all it's a graveyard
even I'm thinking we had a line up in
ascending order just because that is so
slay to do it would probably look better
with your like matching pot set but you
know what that's okay play with how big
or small you want it I'm gonna drop all
of these and they're gonna break so I'm
gonna put this down night and day oh
that looks fantastic
so it has come to my attention that I
have the wrong storage things in here
I'm pretty sure that I've been using
like your classic like Fork spoon knife
holder thing in here no wonder Nothing
fits like that's not the right storage
thing we got a new storage container and
I'm thinking that this one will work
better because it actually has room to
put stuff in it as opposed to this like
what sorry sorry I'll clean you up but
like
oh my God
we're good we're gonna put this thing in
here and then that way now we have some
space to put our like oven mitt and then
we also obviously like put our actual
utensils I can't wait to show my
roommate
this poor poor space cupboard needs a
little love too people it is a nightmare
in there look at this ready ah so we're
gonna free up that room right now with
the shelf stuff can go under stuff can
go on top stuff can go to the side huh
where to start my goodness half of this
video I feel like is me just realizing I
don't need half of the stuff in these
cupboards so I just have to throw it out
oh my God there's so much oil so gross
okay so we're gonna put this stuff now
in here so organized just so organized
maybe I'll put like stuff that I've
literally never looked at in my life
maybe towards the back I might get more
shelves because why not I mean look at
that I went from boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom
I have a real treat for everyone now
look at this space look at this space
dead empty even so why not put a little
cart maybe it's on Wheels maybe it's not
what we have here is wonderful why you
ask we have some counter space we have
some drawers I mean worlds are oyster it
doesn't matter how you're opening it it
opens on both sides slap this bad boy
right over here now that we have our
little cart here we're gonna deck it out
with some goodies
[Music]
we have a couple cutting boards in our
household but like this oh my I mean you
could snap this in half they're not
quality they're kind of small I invested
in a quality cutting board that also
maximizes the space so this thing
can hang over the sink so you know
you're washing your strawberries right
and boom you're doing that over here
boom boom bang or maybe you're chopping
up some Tomatoes you got so much juice
everywhere you need to slide that baby
off oh you don't want this here
get rid of it this thing is so cool
because look at this ready ready
that is so much okay so I love this it's
basically like a little Tupperware Vibe
something you could store stuff in and I
love that it's expandable oh wait a
minute okay ready yup okay so maybe you
want a little big opening here and then
a little drainage also do whatever the
gosh darn heck you want people because
this thing is so versatile so I was just
asked for my baking sheets are and I was
like where are they where are they and I
remembered
we put them in the oven and then it came
to my attention I was informed that
I have this storage under here that's
what that is for I was just I don't I
can't even tell you what I was thinking
because I don't know what I was thinking
I wasn't thinking an easy cool trick
ly maximize your
major easy peasy
well there you have it this has been a
long day I will admit this place was a
mess before I think that we used a lot
of fun methods and just general cleaning
up the space as well as adding a few fun
flares I mean come on I think we did a
great job I do think that my roommate is
going to be very pleased with me so let
me know what your favorite part was
which of these methods you want to use
which of these methods you already use
currently and hey any methods I missed
because Lord knows I missed a lot I'm
sure there's so many things out there so
let me know have a good one everyone
mwah mwah
[Music]